الافريقيه موطن تنازع نفوذ ومصالح بين
الولايات المتحده والصينه ومعظم دول
القاره تحاول عدم الانحياز لدوله على حساب
الاخرى واشنطن وبيكين استخدمتا قوتهما
لوضع اسس للتعاون في مختلف المجالات مع
دول افريقيه حاليا تقوم نائبه الرئيس كما
لهاريس بجوله في القاره وفي وقت لاحق من
العام يتوقع ان ياتي الرئيس الامريكي نفسه
هذه الزيارات تعكس ادراكا متزايدا لحاجه
الولايات المتحده الى تعميق روابطها
بالقاره اعتمادا على الصداقه وليس الوصايه
بدات حارس زيارتها من خانه وفي عام 2022
صدرت الولايات المتحده الى غانا منتجات ب
800 مليون دولار اما غانا فكانت حصيله
صادراتها للولايات المتحده عن نفس الفتره
670 مليون دولار اكثر من نصف الرقم كان
للنفط الخام اذا ما انتقلنا للعلاقه
الاقتصاديه بين الصين فحجمها يزيد بمقدار
الضعف عما ذكرناه قبل قليل وردات الصين
لغانا العام الماضي تجاوزت سته مليارات
و800 مليون دولار في مواردات الصين من
غانا بلغت مليارا و300 مليون دولار في
الجانب السياسي تشدد الولايات المتحده على
قضيه الديمقراطيه في علاقاتها مع الدول
الافريقيه
فهي تنتهج سياسه عدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للبلدان مهما كان شكل الحكم فيها
[موسيقى]
انا متحمسه جدا لمستقبل افريقيا انا
متحمسه جدا لتاثير مستقبل افريقيا على
بقيه العالم بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عندما انظر الى ما يحدث في هذه
القاره حقيقه ان متوسط العمر هو 19 عاما
وما ينبئ به ذلك من نمو الفرص والابتكار
والامكانيات ارى في كل ذلك فرصه عظيمه ليس
فقط لشعوب هذه القاره ولكن لشعوب العالم